yesterday I told you that us sources
confirmed that at least some of the
contents of this infamous Russia Trump
blackmail file are true and shortly
after yesterday's show a report claims
that the NSA National Security Agency is
so worried about the ties between Donald
Trump and Russia that they are hiding
information from Trump during the
intelligence briefings a truly stunning
revelation according to a former NSA
analyst and counterintelligence officer
some of the American spy agencies have
started to withhold info from Donald
Trump for the last three weeks for fear
that quote listen to this the Kremlin
has ears inside the White House
Situation Room an NSA official said to
the New York Observer that it's holding
back some of the quote good stuff from
the White House and the Pentagon worker
said there's not much the Russians don't
know at this point since January 20
we've assumed that the Kremlin has ears
inside the Situation Room there's really
no need to actually hide it from Trump
if you just put it on page two of
anything you hand him we know he only
reads three to four bullet points and
whatever pictures are on page one
seriously though Pat the NSA was holding
information from the president because
of suspected connections to a foreign
foreign nation unreal yeah and I
wouldn't be surprised if Donald Trump
chooses to fire Michael Rogers who's the
NSA director he did that to the acting
Attorney General Sally Yates just about
a week or two ago and she was a a Barack
Obama holdover as well yeah so he may be
doing that if it if he shown signs that
he's disloyal listen if it's true that
the Russians have ears in the Situation
Room our national security has been
compromised full stop there's no other
qualifying sentences or words that I
need to add to that and this is on top
of recent reports that a National
Security Advisor Michael Flynn is also
compromised by Russia we know that he
has now resigned and absolute
utter shame after straight-up lying
about conversations he claimed not to
have had with the Russian ambassador
nine sources told The Washington Post
that they had discussed those sanctions
as we talked about earlier in the show
General Flint twice denied it turns out
it was true he has now resigned at this
point
I wonder if intelligence agencies are
using the canary trap method to expose
leaks this is a method where you as an
intelligence agency you give slightly
different versions of information to
different people and then when there's a
leak you can match up the leak to the
version that you gave to someone so for
example like if I wanted to figure out
whether Pat or melody the intern who's
here today are leaking information to
Russia I might give them similar
information but I would maybe present it
in a different order and use very
particular vocabulary in the version I
give to Pat and in the version I give to
melody so that that way if I go on the
internet and read about the leak I might
be able to match up the vocabulary to
one of the two versions it would help me
figure out who was leaking it it's very
possible that with their interactions
with the Trump White House intelligence
agencies are using the canary trap
method it's kind of like when you're in
high school and you suspect one of your
friends of spreading rumors about you
yeah so you make up a story and until
each one of your friends something
slightly different so you can backtrack
and find out who it was exactly and
Congress this is a bad sign this is a
bad sign about your fearless leader this
might be a good time to start full
fledged formal investigations into
what's going on with Donald Trump in
Russia next thing you know Congress will
announce an investigation of the
intelligence agencies for being really
mean and withholding information from
Donald Trump we're probably not going to
see real action from Republicans until I
guess the 2018 midterms I'm convinced
that that a lot of these Republicans are
still unsure whether they might hurt
themselves by coming out against Trump
too early in terms of the reelection
chances even though it's abundantly
clear now when we've heard of
Alfre and we've heard it from a number
of other people even Republicans that
there are real concerns about Trump it's
still not obvious I think with a 40%
approval for Trump that coming out
against him will benefit them in the
midterms well even in just this past
election Republicans were split on
whether they were going to stick to
Trump or defects from him and it seems
like the people who decided to come out
against him for the most part Lassa
reelection yes many of them did it's
absolutely true it's just very weird
that we're talking about the president
and basically he's being treated like a
little kid who everyone sucks up to in
public on the playground and whatnot but
they're actually scared of and no he's
completely nuts and might punch them in
the face if they're mean but behind the
scenes they're all like what with it
that we don't want to play with this kid
it doesn't make any sense he's scaring
us and he's really really mean can you
imagine what the response would be from
House or Senate Republicans if it were a
Democrat in the White House and we
learned that intelligence agencies are
withholding information because of
suspected connections to a Russian power
there would already be half a dozen
investigations jason Chaffetz would have
launched probably six or eight of them
there would be preparations for
impeachment proceedings there might even
be discussions of treason charges but
it's Trump two Republican no need to do
that and also the Democrats are not very
good at fighting back even when they
have a great case in front of them
that's another issue it's not just the
Republican double standard it also can
be sometimes v I don't know what the
right word is to use an ability tepid
mas' tepid Ness and I think tepid miss
is what I was looking for follow me on
Twitter at D Pakman follow the show on
twitter at david pakman show send me
your thoughts about the Russia chaos
that is going on right now today's show
is brought to you by go daddy where you
can buy your own domain name build a
website or use any of Go Daddy's
business tools you can save 30 percent
at Tri godaddy.com slash David GoDaddy
has actually been the official host of
the David Pakman show website for many
many many years the 24/7 customer
support has been a very good thing for
us I've called them at really odd times
when we've had website issues and they
are always available they are the
largest domain registrar and whether you
have a new idea you're an established
business you're creating a personal
website or moving your large enterprise
site over to GoDaddy they can do it all
thirteen million customers try it and
get 30% off at try go daddy.com slash
David